hello welcome to this video and okay how
many many mistake them I forgot to press
the record button that was silly so I
was commentating nicely into thin air
basically but the game that has screwed
up was actually quite interesting
because of some strategic features that
are useful to know so I'm going to
basically do a post-mortem commentary of
this game who I am and this move autumn
we got into enemies of Indian with 96
this is the zero variation and it's
something that I featured from the black
side in my limbs iboga book so it's not
the kind of line that I know nothing
about so so this is all very normal
white he has a couple of good lines III
I mean good lines mean not like he's
better in every line but he's got some
choice I like before him get gaining
lots of space on the queenside black
played 5 d5 night back eform yeah this
is one of the I think more promising
lines that white has available against
is erick grabbing lots of space and now
black made a couple of decisions that
don't fit into this position but it's
useful to understand why they don't work
and what would be better
he played Bishop g4 this is not really
great the problem is that this bishop is
not going to be traded if black would be
sure that the bishop would be traded for
example if the bishop white bishop would
be here you can be reasonably sure that
after Knight means those bishops would
trade but that's not the case here I was
immediately retweeting this and now this
bishop is basically staring into thin
air it head doesn't have anything useful
to do
and also the bishop does not really do
anything on g6 or h5 or something so it
really has no good purpose there
what should black do in this position
one key strategic idea is to play f5
that is something that is very much in
line with the pawn structure of course
like in the Kings Indian or so you want
to want to play a five here it is very
difficult to ever to get this going
the move Knight h5 would be perfectly
fine if not for a particular reply the
reply is g3 this is a problem now f5
does not work due to Knight H form and
white is threatening to take here and
play this fork on g6 this is basically
lost for black it's really close to lost
yeah you have a terrible position that
means this straight forward counter play
does not work note and then I played
Bishop g5 early on and after h6 drop
back provoking h6 is actually quite
important here if you compare this
position would be perfectly fine for
black if the pawn is on h7s then Knight
h4 is not a problem there's no hold on
g6 so this is a nice little nuance
playing ownership g5 first and then
going back so what should black do
actually in my book and have this as a
black position in my book so I don't
think black is in terrible shape and I
recommended a 5 and I see it's that even
what stockfish recommends nowadays and
back then
I analyzed it it's it's it was analyzed
in 2014-2015 I was mostly using the
versions back then of of Houdini and
Komodo stockfish was already strong but
not as strong as today so a 5 y 5 black
wants to gain a little bit of space on
inside and possibly just trade on the fr
like take on before take on a1 you've
got less space you want to trade that
decent idea one important point is that
black has to set up the right pawn
structure on the green side and it took
me about to understand back then what
the right pawn structure is and it is
the following
I'm just making moves now that kind of
kind of fits but not don't take it as
the best most so let's say white wants
to avoid the trades like notes right
here so he moves the rook
so what black should do now is to take
and place his six and this is important
we see six your intention with black is
to take on d5 and make the pawn
structure completely aesthetic what I
mean is that in this position there are
no pawn levers there's no pawn play on
the Queen side and that means that the
bishops
have a hard time to get into play
because the position cannot open up
fully there's the C file a file open but
you cannot really play with porn storms
let's say if you imagine black is not
doing this and just stays then at some
point I have maybe c5 Knight here b5
Bishop before I can play them with this
with this pawn avalanche and in this
kind of position this is not as easily
possible black and in fact is quite okay
here it's not I mean I'm not saying
black is better or anything but it is a
position that you can play without being
too much afraid so what happened in the
game he played Bishop g4 as mentioned
and with 92 I'm avoiding the trades and
now there's a second problem so black he
played b6 and this is almost always a
strategic mistake in such a position
almost always because you just give up
flexibility the move c5 cannot be
prevented in the law
almost impossible to prevent anyway and
will be six you're weakening your light
squares quite a bit and you make it more
difficult to place these six after all
okay I played Bishop d3 and I went 97
and now I went Knight f1 the knight is
perfectly placed on e3
aiming towards f5 this whole situation
with their v square is even more
critical after I provoked this h6 move
because this way it is more difficult
for black to play g6 for example I mean
that's not really create anyway but it's
once the nines on f5 you cannot kick it
away as g6 Hanks h6 yeah this is already
really difficult for black to to play
this position your bishop is is offside
and he tried this move and okay I'm
happy with this tempo and now H form
threatening g4 Bishop c6h5 winning the
bishop yeah
now what nameplate Knight df6 and with
f3 i reinforce this g4 idea now this
position I think is strategically
winning already it's it's very difficult
to turn to imagine how black should save
himself there the relatively bests
probably Bishop g6g form and now maybe
h5 I mean it is just just disastrous
ready so h v g5 and now you can go
Knight a5 but it's not necessary can
also play just the king here and then we
know on the Queen side it's just it's a
terribly bad position like has no space
and no active play and in the game he
played g5 which shortened the whole
misery after G form the bishop has no
squares yeah after Bishop d6 h5 it's
gone he took here and after night F
then resigned I can't just take the
bishop next move so I felt it was
interesting to discuss the strategic
implications of this position type and
therefore it's a bit of shame err I also
did that in the life commentary but I
screwed it up with the live one so let's
do a little bit of a post-mortem there
thanks a lot for watching guys